all right absolute last thing on the
wacky weekend in anchorage alaska
uh the asinine anchorage at alaska
weekend
um my pillow ceo mike lindell did show
up at the rally he claimed that votes
were stoled from donald trump in alaska
now i know
english is my second language
but
votes were stoled from donald trump
sounds wacky and it also sounds untrue
trump won in alaska by the way do you
all know here in alaska over 29 000
votes were stole from donald trump
oh god i mean it's uh
the you saturday night live is going to
be out of business you all know here in
alaska over 29 000 votes were stolen
from donald trump right
so
it happened everywhere in our country
and uh as you all know i've said it we
have to get rid of the machines and the
voting machines right
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines now remember that
in alaska donald trump won easily in
2020
um
52-42 very very easy win
but pillow is convinced votes were
stoled from donald trump and then lastly
i know at this point
it's indistinguishable from satire but
mike pillow has a new date for donald
trump being reinstated and it's next
month it's about five six weeks away
either august 20th or 21st it will be
the biggest
thing
in our lifetimes
um
and it might be what gets donald trump
finally reinstated this is so exciting
because
it is all going to lead up everybody to
and i've got to say this august 20th and
21st the biggest event this country in
our lifetime i believe it's the most
important event you're ever for
in our lifetime what this is going to do
this will be in springfield missouri
live stream to the world the natural
place of course for the biggest event of
our lifetimes i mean no offense to
springfield missouri but surprising
certainly that that's where the biggest
event is going to take place
and it's a two-day event it's invite
only you guys will be there yeah you
said that it's an invitation so it's in
spring springfield missouri yeah
springfield missouri is so important
they'll be if you know the invites will
be going out these will be influencers
podcasters grassroots um it'll be uh
church leaders okay and when we do this
everybody imagine every state will be
getting up there saying uh you know
here's our footprint you're all going to
hear what the good going where's our
hope you know and then the next day will
be everything of uh
what what your state can do individually
to get to yep so very very clear it's
going to be an incredible august 20th
and 21st now you guys may or may not
remember but
mike pillow during my interview with him
actually said i could go to his
symposium if i wanted that he referred
to it as the symbosium but i think it
was a cyber symposium he said if i
wanted to go to that i could he gave his
personal cell phone number maybe i mean
i know that there's so many church
leaders that are going to be there that
they might not have room for me but
should i contact pillow and say sir i'd
love to go to the biggest event of our
lifetimes and and check out what's going
to go on and how every state is going to
do this or maybe i'll just stay home i
don't know let me know what you think i
should do so that closes the loop
on this wild and wacky weekend asinine
anchorage alaska rally
uh not particularly full it was a 5 000
seat venue
whose upper deck was not uh completely
sold out there were actually seats
everywhere
so i know it's alaska and there's not
that many people there so maybe that's
what's to blame maybe
the glisten and shine of trump is
receding actually trump was glistening a
lot but that was he was sweating on
saturday night
we will look at the data coming up soon
so that does it on this topic for today
we're going to take a quick break we are
going to review
an absolute clinic master class by pete
budej on fox news over the weekend we're
going to talk about
um
these boring gun talking points being
shut down by senator dick durbin we have
a lot still to come
facebook.com davidpakmanshow make sure
you give us a like and we will be right
back